منذ ان مزحت ملاك ذات السنوات العشر مع
اسرتها
تراجعت حالتها الصحيه ملاك مصابه بمتلازمه
داون والعيش في الخيام يفرض عليها مزيدا
من العزله
ووالدتها فشلت في دفعها للتكيف مع الحياه
هنا
على الجبال ازرق
في مخيم وطن للنازحين شمال ادلب يعيش
عشرون شخصا من المصابين بمتلازمه داون
يعانون سوء فهم المجتمع لحالتهم ولا
يتلقون اي تعليم او تدريبات تخص حالتهم
الرعايه لابنائهم المصابين بمتلازمه داون
يكبر الابناء هنا وتسوء حالتهم كل ما طالت
الاقامه في الخيام فالمخيمات بعيده عن
المدن حيث المراكز المتخصصه بتقديم
الرعايه لهم
التحق بعض المصابين بمتلازمه داون في
مدينه ادلب بمركز صحي متخصص وهذه الاصابه
يسببها التراب جيني خلقي ويعاني المصابون
من مشكلات عقليه وتاخر في النمو لذلك
يتلقون هنا تدريبات تنمي قدراتهم وتهدفه
الى دمجهم في المجتمع
[موسيقى]
من تحقيق اهداف الخطه العلاجيه رغم
المصاعب الكبيره التي تواجه العمل
لا نستطيع الوصول لها بسبب عدم توفر
امكانيه النقل والمواصلات واضف الى ذلك
نقص توعيه الاهل بهذا الجانب يحتاج الكثير
من عائله توعيه باهميه ارسال المراكز
للتعليم
في المجتمع بشكل جميل
التخلص من اثار الحرب من مهام المركز
الاساسيه فمن الاطفال ايتام واخرون يعانون
الخوف المفرط لكن كثيرا من المصابين خارج
المركزوليه للجهات الرسميه والمنظمات
الدوليه بسبب قله اهتمامها بمثل تلك
الامراض كما تقول صهيب الخلف الجزيره ادلب